we are joined now by valerie jarrett
she's a former senior advisor for
president barack obama and reince
priebus
who is president trump's former chief of
staff reince i want to start with you
first picking up on the mike pompeo's
story
he started the speech reince as you saw
saying i'm susan's husband and i'm
nick's dad
but nobody could uh miss the fact that
he also had his mike pompeo secretary of
state
face on and that it was a very political
speech
now normally you know that we don't mix
up government and politics
on this particular in this particular
time what did you think of him breaking
the norm did it concern you at all
uh not really gail by the way good
morning to you and valerie and the gang
um yeah not really you know the hatch
acts kind of uh
it's it's a law that that makes sure
that people that are political or they
have a federal position like a chief of
staff like me or valerie jarrett a
senior counselor that when it comes time
for campaigning that you only do that on
personal time and so
it's just like the president using air
force one and you've had to split up the
costs and the campaign pays for part and
you know i think in the case of mike
pompeo a big part
of the portfolio of trump is going to be
confronting china
israel trade and all those issues i
think are going to be very important
uh in this election so office of legal
counsel which is a
an official sort of third-party body
that reviews these things
also approved it so but reins he did
conversation but it's but he did violate
his own department's policy
yeah and i haven't seen that but i i do
know that it's completely
unconstitutional to prevent people
from using their personal time
if they want to be involved in policy
just like me going to a trump rally when
i was the chief of staff
i mean i did that i did those things
quite a bit
but i but we also had to account for my
time
in a way that was legal and so that's
really i think what's going on here now
whether
they're violating their own policies i
don't know about that but i do know what
the law says
and as far as what the law says he's
fine to do it
all right there are some republicans
though who disagree with that but
valerie what did you think of the impact
of that speech
well it wasn't just the secretary of
state doing it was also the fact that
they held
much of the ceremony in the white house
in the rose garden
girl that's totally unprecedented to do
and
even further to have gone up on the
state floor and had a naturalization
ceremony
no one can argue that that is anything
but official business
uh as a backdrop to a political campaign
all of this is totally unprecedented
um it certainly in my opinion violates
the hatch act but certainly
if not the law is certainly the spirit
we want to separate
politics from government and that did
not happen last night it wasn't a
blurring of the lines
it was an erasing of the line well it
was a big night last night for melania
trump our first lady and
people on both sides of the aisle say
that she delivered that she delivered
that you know it was her job they said
to go out and humanize her husband
i'm curious about valerie starting with
you what stood out to you
in that speech it was very personal
yes it was but i don't see how one
speech can whitewash over the damage
that her husband has done over the
nearly
last four years and when she talks about
social media well who has weaponized it
more than her husband
she was the first person to call the
coronavirus corona
covid19 as opposed to the china virus
that was notable and she expressed
support and sympathy for people who have
lost their lives during the coronavirus
and that's something that we have not
heard
in the first two nights of this
convention right
well you're exactly yeah exactly
yeah um first of all i think she did a
superb job number one
she acknowledged the pandemic in a way
that i thought was very
very human she she was reflective
on race relations which i think is
really important right now
and not to mention some of the other
speakers that i think were excellent
when it comes to race
she was speaking directly to suburban
women as well which is
really a lot of you know as valerie
knows in these
in the rust belt in in in around this
battleground state that's really
important and she humanized her husband
at the end of the speech so i mean she
did hit it out of the park
i do think the republicans are going to
get a bump here and
um as far as the hatch x is concerned
all of those things have been approved
by officer legal counsel and
the democrats aren't going to win
debating the hatch act i promise you
that
right so in both nights of this
convention uh the republicans have
painted a pretty rosy picture of how
they've dealt with the coronavirus we
have 178 thousand
dead however larry cuddly kudlow even
referred to it in the past tense
do you think there's a risk that the
people will see that things aren't over
and maybe things aren't so good
well again i refer you back to melania
trump's speech i think
her tone i would tell you i think that's
the tone
needed at the rnc is exactly what
melania trump
did in her speech um and yeah i
i don't disagree with you i think that
the coronavirus is probably the number
one issue
on the ballot and second to that is the
economy and i think ultimately it's
going to be a very tight race
people have strong feelings about both
of those issues
and um that's what it's going to come
down to but so far
this week i think the rnc has done a
pretty fabulous job
in in in diversity and in
tackling these topics and building up
their candidate
which is what they need to do all right
reince priebus valerie jarrett thank you
both for being with us this morning